nous voudrions aussi savoir quel sera le
premier choix de gardien de but pour
notre équipe nationale
je pense qu'il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un
doute là dessus
le gardien de but de l'équipe nationale
sera bien sûr mais toi ça fait vite le
fil chine
[Applaudissements]
rabia
l'efs
il a reçu les honneurs des maîtres
d'espoir et de son équipe il s'agit de
la vie en chine le real madrid est un
grand club mais je suis trop attaché au
système
est comme ça notre pays pour être fiers
de vous
le montant qu'il sera qui vous êtes
on vous l'a dehors
on n'a pas besoin d'un autre commis tch
le football
c'est vivant
ce n'est jamais pareil c'est une
perpétuelle évolution
je te comprends pas le diovan tu as de
bonnes mains t'es pas un imbécile
pourquoi tu as besoin de ce fou du puy
il faut que quelqu'un paie
pour la défaite de notre équipe
la chine a fait son temps voilà
iasi et une content pour l'équipe
c'est une football les anciens exploits
sans combat ce sont les résultats
actuels qui importe
quand tu joueras pour l'équipe nationale
alors n'oublie jamais que tu n'es pas
juste là pour attraper une balle on
y lit à ton pays derrière toi
la batterie est là alcante
elle compte sur toi
tâche de lui faire honneur
vous êtes ga chine c'est moi oui est ce
que vous pourriez le prouver